voilà jma sa grand moment c'est un grand
moment que j'attends depuis des années
michèle cotta
interview alerte aux roses
voilà bonsoir t'as vu au 2 et y sur
trois le bateau très bien j'aime
regarder votre caméra équitable du baril
d'aller se coucher
bien vous êtes sages et en français la
patronne à michel vous préférez draguer
ou vous faire draguer perdre préféré
larguer ou vous faire larguer largué
vous préféré embrasser ou vous faire
embrasser s'embrasser caresser vous
faire car et c'est vraiment un égoïsme
incroyable à se faire car ici pas quel
est pour vous michèle cotta le vieux
idéal pour faire l'amour annie clés beta
ouais j'ai des photos dans ton bureau
monsieur le lieu où il vous est
impossible de faire l'amour france 3
et les villes
via les cas une histoire horrible en
toile est ce qu on dit que les gens qui
ont des grosses voitures ont les petites
bitton - est-ce que vous avez besoin de
faire l'amour pour aimer des mets pour
faire l'amour
le ferney beaucoup aimé à serrar ce
adriana c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas
moi c'est celle diversité combien moyal
est ce que vous préférez un homme qui
baisent bien mais pierre fidèles les
connais par coeur mais un homme qui
baisent bien mais qu'un fidèle aux
hommes qui mangent mal mais qui est
fidèle mais ça fait toujours s'arranger
on y tenait sidel s'arrange pas allez
donc vous comptez sur vous pour
l'arranger non à ses six coaccusés sur
la question posée elle est quand même la
tête du paf à connaître
a capella tapotage est-ce que vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec mille
hommes toujours de la même façon
ou avec un homme de mille façons
différentes c'est une trentaine de
réalisme
est-ce que vous préféreriez que votre
mari à la pâte a fait coucher avec une
autre en pensant à vous ou couché avec
vous en pensant à une autre voilà c'est
une question tout m'a beaucoup
interpellé
si vous là bas aussi bien j'ai écouté
sont trois ans avec moi on consent
quelqu'un d'autre évidemment ça je
faisais quoi bon des comptes de nombre
de personnes ont alors fait ma pension à
vous c'est énorme c'est la moitié de la
france et son histoire
comment est-ce que vous préféreriez que
christian karembeu couche avec vous en
pensant à une autre ou couche avec une
autre on pensera à vous a oui couché
avec l'entrée en pensant à moi ice et
d'agacement systématiquement opposée à
ces deux machines
vous êtes très pratique c'est vrai le
seul à michel aulas est ce que dans ces
s'est trompé non quand la fille a les
cernant le no1 rappelons le principal
jean auclair du mali pierre dumayet
est-ce que embrasser s'est trompé non
est ce que vous connaissez michel rocard
jusque rennais messieurs s'est trompé
personne avec lui
oui
et
michèle cotta avait là messieurs michèle
cotta